Це належить комусь з загиблих.
Як тільки закінчилися бої на барикадах, принесли.
Я питаю: "А це…?" А вони:
"Ви правильно зрозуміли, що сталося з цією людиною…"
Речі загиблих євромайданівців.
Плакати, які вони тримали в руках.
Оцей предмет, може бути, належав Нігояну.
Там де він читає Шевченка...
Ікони, намальовані просто на дошках з барикад.
Всі ці "артефакти Революції" чотири роки тому
врятувала Музейна сотня Євромайдану.
Київська художниця Наталка Кадин-Фесенюк - одна з них.
Під час трагічних подій вдалося врятувати
від знищення понад 2000 експонатів.
В тому, що одного дня в Києві буде створено Музей революції,
особисто Наталка та її однодумці не сумнівалися.
Тож його майбутні експонати активісти старанно
зберігали у приватних квартирах і будинках.
У 2016 році офіційно був заснований Національний
меморіальний комплекс Героїв Небесної сотні -
Музей Революції Гідності.
Відтоді діючий музей проводить виставки, отримує фінансування,
але все ще не має жодного приміщення.
Його експонати тимчасово зберігаються у вільних
приміщеннях деяких музеїв Києва.
Ці ж коробки та пакунки знаходиться в одному
з підвалів у центрі столиці.
Тут немає ані опалення, ані спеціального музейного
обладнання, тож деякі експонати – під загрозою.
Воно вже починає лупитися, відшаровуватися
Стараємося його мінімально діставати,
мінімально травмувати ці речі.
Музей Революції, де гідно зберігатимуться експонати,
планують побудувати ось тут - на горі, на вулиці Інститутській.
Директор музею, теж активіст Музейної сотні Євромайдану,
мріє, що це не буде місцем пам’яті радянського ґатунку.
Так званий дім свободи, своєрідну платформу
дляпереосмислення минулого
Саме такою є головна ідея концепції Музею.
Її розробляли не лише українці, а й німецькі експерти,
які ділилися своїм досвідом презентації трагічних сторінок історії.
Їхній підхід є такий досить сприйнятливий для нас.
Форма є лаконічна.
Меморіал надає різні точки зору,
іці форми є сучасні, продумані,
економічно обґрунтовані і досить промовисті.
І вони не стільки дають відповіді на запитання,
а спонукають до думок, пошуку індивідуальних
відповідей, не нав’язують міфи і стереотипи.
Право на проведення міжнародного конкурсу
архітектурних проектів Музею революції
виграла німецька компаніяPhase1.
Нині міжнародне журі саме визначило переможця
"Меморіалу Героїв Небесної Сотні".
Це проект архітекторок зі Львова.
Вже влітку буде визначений і проект Музею.
Наталка Фесенюк сподівається, що будівництво
завершиться упродовж 5-7 років.
І за цей час іржа і пліснява не знищить
усі ці "артефакти Революції Гідності".